Ich fange um die Einwohnerin.
Ich höre.
Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Yujal.
Ich bin der Diensthabender auf dieser Station und möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie ein Verständnis?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Bevor wir zu Ihren aktuellen Bescheiden kommen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Kurt Bergmann.
Mit double N.
Am Ende ja.
Am Ende ja. Okay.
Herr Bergmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 55.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 5. März 68.
68.
Wie groß sind Sie? Wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
Ich bin 71 und ich wiege so 82 kg.
Okay Herr Bergmann, was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, also ich habe solche starken Schmerzen in meinem rechten Handgelenk.
Und zwar, ja, muss ich dazusagen, ich habe mich vorhin auf dem halben Weg von der Arbeit.
Wenn ich mit dem Motorrad gestürzt, da war eine Stelle, wo es rutschig war und ja, da hat es mich hingelegt.
Ich habe zum Glück ein Helm aufgehabt, aber ich bin auf die rechte Seite gefallen mit dem Motorrad.
Also ich hatte zunächst das Gefühl, dass alles gut gegangen, ich könnte weiterfahren.
Aber jetzt, wo ich dann zu Hause war, habe ich dann gemerkt, dass die rechte Hand, dass die ganz dick wird und dass das auch unglaublich weh tut.
Im Brustbereich tut es mir auch ein bisschen weh.
Ich glaube, ich habe mir auch unter der Jeans ein bisschen am Bein und an der Hüfte die Haut abgeschürft.
Aber das ist nicht so schrecklich schlimm, aber das tut halt weh, wenn ich da irgendwie gegen komme oder so.
Aber die Hand ist wirklich schlecht und da habe ich gedacht, ich muss doch mal vorsichtseilbar zu Ihnen kommen.
Ja, Sie haben gut gemacht und wann sind Sie hier gekommen?
Ich bin jetzt vor wenigen Minuten, ich musste jetzt nicht lange warten hier draußen.
Okay, wann ist der Unfall passiert?
Ja, das ist vielleicht so zwei Stunden her, eineinhalb Stunden.
Ich war halt auf dem Heimweg nach der Arbeit und wie gesagt, dann habe ich es eigentlich noch bis zu Hause geschafft.
Und dann, als ich die Maschine abgestellt habe und drin war, habe ich mit einmal gemerkt, puh, das geht mir doch nicht so gut.
Und dann habe ich erst die Hand so ein bisschen gekühlt, aber das wurde auch nicht wirklich besser.
Und dann hat mich meine Frau jetzt mit dem Auto hergebracht.
Okay, Sie sind mit seiner Frau zusammen hier gefahren.
Meine Frau hat mich im Auto hier hergebracht, genau.
Sind Sie auf dem Weg von der Arbeit nach Hause gewesen?
Ich war auf dem Weg von der Arbeit nach Hause, ja.
Okay, Herr Bergmann, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerze, die California-Einsbis sehen,
wobei sie ja leicht und senziell stark in Schmerzen entspricht.
Oh, also die Hand, das tut schon richtig weh.
Ich würde sagen, das ist so sieben bis acht bestimmt.
Schraben, die Schmerzen, ihr könnt wohin aus.
Na ja, die sind so im Handgelenk, ja, so, ich denke, so ein bisschen strahlt es in die Hand
und ich kann halt die ganze Hand gar nicht bewegen.
Und ja, also ich denke in die Hand strahlt es so ein bisschen aus.
Okay, in rechten Hand.
Ja, genau.
Ich bin auf die rechte Seite gefallen.
Rechte Hand, auf der rechten Seite auch, hingefallen.
Im rechte Hand und strahlt die Schmerzen in der Hand.
Okay, haben Sie Luftnot?
Ja, so ganz schlimme, ich kriege wohl Luft, aber ich merke,
dass es weh tut, wenn ich tief einatme.
Beim Ausatmen geht es und das funktioniert auch alles.
Aber beim Einatmen merke ich, dass es mir weh tut, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Herzstraße oder Herzklopfen?
Ich glaube, so direkt nach dem Unfall hatte ich so ein bisschen Herzklopfen
vor Aufregungen, dann hat man ja so den Schreck.
Aber jetzt würde ich sagen, habe ich das nicht.
Haben Sie vor dem Unfall oder nach dem Unfall Ihr Beutsein verloren?
Nee, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Ihr Kopf nicht verletzt haben?
Nein, ich hatte ein Helm auf, wie immer.
Und ich hatte eigentlich auch eine gute Jacke an.
Ja, Sie haben das gut gemacht.
Aber ja, das Handgelenk oder die Hand ist halt irgendwie so dazwischen gekommen.
Okay.
Und gegen die Schmerzen haben Sie etwas, einige Medikamente eingehauen?
Nein, bisher habe ich noch nichts genommen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das unter kaltes Wasser gehalten,
in der Hoffnung, dass das vielleicht ein bisschen die Schmerzen weggenimmt.
Aber das hat nicht viel geholfen.
Ja, die Kühlung hat Ihnen nicht geholfen.
Ja, das hat es vielleicht so ein bisschen für den Augenblick gelindert,
aber die Schmerzen sind immer noch irre.
Können Sie Ihr rechter Handgelenk in alle Rüstungen bewegen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Also das tut sofort weh.
Ich probiere das jetzt natürlich auch nicht gegen den Widerstand.
Ich denke, das ist auch geschwollen, wenn ich mir das angucke.
Ich habe das nicht geholfen, wenn ich mir das angucke.
Das tut super.
Ja.
Okay.
Aber das ist auch nicht so, wenn ich die Schmerzen bewegen.
Also wenn man die Schmerzen bewegen kann?
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Haben Sie irgendjemanden, der Blut per Güsse oder Belauf bemerkt?
Ja, ja, an der Hüfte.
Und ich glaube auch hier so seitlich am Rostkorb.
Und wahrscheinlich auch an den Beinen.
Ich habe da noch gar nicht so genau geguckt.
Aber das tut alles ziemlich weh.
Aber nicht so wie das Handgelenk.
Und haben Sie Hautabschürfung bemerkt?
Ja, ja, ich war auf der Toilette und da habe ich die Hose runtergemacht.
Da habe ich das gesehen, dass da an der Wade und am Knie
und so ein bisschen die Haut abgeschürft ist.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann, haben Sie Fieber?
Huch, habe ich das nicht gemessen, aber glaube ich nicht.
Stülphoros nach Schweist.
Man sie normalerweise.
Eigentlich sonst bin ich eigentlich relativ gesund.
Das Einzige, was ich habe,
ich habe häufiger mal so ein bisschen schnelle Verdauung.
Ja, ich würde ein paar Kuragen für ihr Allgemeinszustand stellen.
Also wie gesagt, sonst, sonst, nachts schlafe ich gut
und ich habe keinen Nachtspreis.
Das Einzige, was bei mir eigentlich als Problem bekannt ist,
dass ich ein bisschen niedrigen Blutdruck habe.
Wenn es mir also nicht so gut geht,
dann muss ich manchmal so Tropfen nehmen,
um den Blutdruck ein bisschen nach oben zu bringen.
Und dann habe ich einen Wandscheibenvorfall gehabt
in der Halswerbesäule.
Und da habe ich halt manchmal, manchmal noch so beschwerden
und muss ein bisschen Krankengymnastik machen eigentlich.
Ist Ihnen überlode schwindelig?
Jetzt ist mir nicht schwindelig, nein.
Müssen Sie schon mal Erbrechen?
Nein, so Glück musste ich mich nicht übergeben, nein.
Okay, in letzter Zeit haben Sie ungewollt gewisch abgenommen
oder so genommen?
Nein, da hat sich nichts geändert.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist es sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Von Wasserlassen eigentlich.
Nicht, weil Stuhlgang, da habe ich halt manchmal so ein bisschen
eine Neigung, dass ich Durchfall habe,
dass ich das schnell reagiere.
Durchfall oder Verstoffung?
Nein, Durchfall.
Ist Ihnen eine Diagnose bekannt?
Und gerne diese Durchfall?
Nein.
Geht es um die Reise?
Okay, können Sie gut schlafen
oder haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Normalerweise schlafe ich eigentlich immer sehr gut.
Wahrscheinlich lacht nicht so gut,
weil mir dieser Arm wehtut.
Sonst geht es mir, kann ich eigentlich gut schlafen.
Ich arbeite viel an der frischen Luft
und da bin ich abend müde.
Herr Bergmann, seit wann leiden Sie an niedrige Blutdruck?
Wahrscheinlich schon richtig lange.
Man hat das vor zehn Jahren mal festgestellt.
Und Sie nehmen dagegen eine Truppe?
Wenn ich merke, dass es mir schlecht geht,
hat man das Gefühl, dass man dann morgens nicht richtig in die Gänge kommt.
Dann nehme ich ein paar Truppen, dass es mir wieder besser geht.
Wenn Sie sich an die Sendnahme von der Medikamente erinnern?
Wie das Zeug heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Das steht immer bei mir oben auf dem Schrank,
damit da niemand dran geht.
Ich habe das nicht vor Augen, wie das heißt.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Bandscheid und Vorfall?
Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Dann hat sich das aber Gott sei Dank wieder gegeben.
Ich habe eine Zeit lang,
musste ich sehr vorsichtig sein, auch bei der Arbeit.
Jetzt ist es aber eigentlich ein bisschen besser.
Ich habe viel Gymnastik gemacht
und ich habe auch keine falschen Bewegungen gemacht.
Nehmen Sie dagegen bei Bedarf eine Schmerzmutter
oder Medikament?
Wenn es schlecht ist, nehme ich mal Ibuprofen.
Wie viel Milligramm und wie viel Mal?
Das sind, glaube ich, 400er. Kann das sein?
Das kann sein.
Wenn Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen leiden,
Sie haben die Abenteilung geholfen.
Das Einzige, was ich sonst noch bekannt ist,
ich habe eigentlich schon als Kind Neurodermitis gehabt.
Das hat sich jetzt auch im Erwachsenenalter noch stabilisiert.
Das ist jetzt nur noch wie außen an den Oberarmen.
Aber da kann das schon im Oberarmen passieren,
dass ich solche Stellen habe und da muss ich dann Cortison-Salve nehmen.
Okay. Regenmäßig?
Nein, das nehme ich eigentlich auch nur, wenn das gerade wieder auftritt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit Stress zusammenhängt
oder was auch immer.
Aber dann habe ich das manchmal.
Entschuldigung, ich muss mal eben meine Nase füllen.
Ja, Sie haben nicht Neurodermitis hängt mit Stress immer zusammen.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, das langt mir auch völlig.
Okay. Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte vor, ja, das ist jetzt auch schon lange her.
Vor 25 Jahren hatte ich eine Nachhiliszenenriss.
Das war eine Sportverletzung und das ist operiert worden.
Danach hat sich das aber alles gut stabilisiert.
Und dann hatte ich noch eine kleine Operation vor fünf Jahren.
Da habe ich mich sterilisieren lassen.
Okay. Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, sonst bin ich immer gut durchgekommen.
Okay. Sind Ihnen Allergie bekannt oder unverträglich,
die Medikamente oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, man hat das damals gesagt, als diese Achilleszenengeschichte war,
dass ich ob das Kontrastmittel reagiert habe
und ich darf also kein Kontrastmittel haben.
Okay. Wie übersetzt die Kontrastmittelallergie?
Ja, damals war das so, dass ich kurzfristig
einen roten Hautausschlag bekommen habe und juckreiz.
Dann habe ich aber gleich ein Medikament bekommen.
Dann hat man mir nur gesagt, ich soll das auf alle Fälle immer angeben.
Ja, Sie sollten immer darauf achten.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergen oder unverträglichkeit?
Nein, sonst meine ich, das ist alles bei mir in Ordnung.
Sehr gut. Ich würde ein paar Fragen über Ihr Gewundheit stellen.
Sind Sie rauchbar?
Ja, ich habe viele, viele Jahre, habe ich ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Aber ja, ich habe so vor fünf Jahren das aufgehört
und jetzt rauche ich noch so gelegentlich.
Ich rauche jetzt noch so vielleicht 50 Egeräten am Tag.
Aber längst nicht mehr ein ganzes Päckchen.
Ja, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Und wie lange haben Sie Zigaretten geraucht,
tägliche Einpackung?
Ja, mein ganzes Erwachsenenleben würde ich sagen, also 20 Jahre bestimmt.
Okay, trinken Sie legalmäßiger Alkohol, Herr Bergmann?
Ja, Alkohol. Ich trinke jeden Abend ein Bier zum Abendessen oder danach.
Ein Bier, oder?
Ja, mal auch zwei, aber regelmäßig ein Bier.
Okay, nehmen Sie bitte nicht Person, nicht dass Sie seine Routine verraten.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen schon, Mann?
Mit Drogen habe ich noch nie Kontakt gehabt, nein.
Okay, was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Bergmann?
Ja, Sie haben einen sehr interessanten Job.
Ich arbeite als Tierpfleger im Zoo.
Sehr schön. Leiden Sie unter Stress oder unter Belastung bei der Arbeit?
Nein, ich mache mir das sehr viel Spaß, der Umgang mit den Tieren.
Und gerade jetzt im Frühjahr, wenn die alle ihre Jungen bekommen,
da muss man sich ja sehr drum kümmern und die dann hoch zu päppeln.
Und so, das macht mir sehr viel Spaß.
Und wir haben auch sehr nette Kollegen da.
Da habe ich eigentlich Glück, ich habe einen sehr guten Job.
Das freut mich sehr schön.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Die sind zwar alle schon relativ groß, aber wohnen alle noch zu Hause.
Sind alle gesund?
Die sind zum Glück alle genommen, ja.
Ja, zum Glück.
Und wahrscheinlich wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, klar, wir wohnen alle zusammen.
Sehr schön, Herr Bergmann.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, mein Vater ist schon vor längerer Zeit verstorben.
Meine Mutter liebt noch.
Darf ich fragen, woran Ihr Vater verstorben ist?
Ja, der hat den Herz infakt.
Und mit welchem Jahr ist er verstorben?
Ja, da war der Anfang 70.
70.
Ist tut mir leid.
Ihre Mutter ist noch am Leben.
Leidet Sie an chronische Vorherkrankungen?
Das Einzige, was ich weiß,
Sie hatte mal so eine kleine Operation,
weil sie an der Schlefe so eine Hautveränderung hatte.
Und da hat man dann gesagt, das ist ein weißer Hautkrebs.
Aber sonst ist sie, glaube ich, ganz gut beieinander.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, die Schwester hat ein bisschen Probleme, die ist magasüchtig.
Aber sonst so organische Erkrankungen
im eigentlichen Sinne hat sie eigentlich nicht.
Okay, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Tetanusimpfung gehabt?
Oh ja, mein Hausarzt ist immer drauf,
weil er weiß, dass ich Motorrad fahre.
Und natürlich auch bei der Arbeit im Zoo müssen wir immer geimpft sein.
Deswegen habe ich, das weiß ich dann sicher,
dass ich die Tetanusimpfung habe
und dass ich auch sonst gegen Corona bin,
ich natürlich auch geimpft.
Sie haben gut gemacht.
Ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen, Herr Bergmann.
Haben Sie Fragen oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Was meinen Sie, was ist mit meiner Hand
und was ist mit diesen komischen Schmerzen beim Atmen?
Was machen wir jetzt als nächstes?
Ich werde Sie direkt aus fürlöschen und untersuchen.
Dann werde ich ein paar Bekämpfendes verfahren,
um eine Fraktur, ein Bruch ausgeschlossen.
Und dann am Ende der Ihre Ergebnisse
können wir sehr viel überlegen,
wo Sie leiden.
Woran ich leide?
Ich hoffe auch, dass man dagegen tun kann.
Ja, mal schauen, wie ich gesagt habe,
es ist ja früh etwas zu sagen,
aber wir sind für Sie da
und wir können alle krankheiten behandeln.
Aber muss ich hier bleiben oder kann ich heute Abend nach Hause?
Wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht nach Hause gehen,
aber zur Seite kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Wir müssen die allerergebnisse bekommen.
Alles klar.
Dann warte ich erst mal ab.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Beusseinlosigkeit vor Unfall oder nach Unfall?
Können Sie alles erinnern?
Ja, er hat es schon gefragt.
Er hat es gefragt, ja, haben Sie vielleicht überhört
und ich habe das verneint.
Ich habe keine Gedächtnislücken.
Ich habe das Bewusstsein nicht verloren.
Okay, danke schön.
Entschuldigung, haben Sie Taubholzgefühl bemerkt?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich würde mal sagen, in der rechten Hand
könnte das sein,
dass ich da so ein Taubholzgefühl habe,
aber das tut alles weh.
Das kann ich noch nicht so richtig einschätzen vom Gefühl.
Es könnte aber sein, dass ich da ein Taubholzgefühl habe.
Im Augen liegt überwiegend die Schmerzen.
Können Sie auf den rechten Bein auftreten?
Auf dem rechten Bein?
Ja, das kann ich.
Ich konnte auch nach Hause laufen,
sogar nach Hause fahren.
Die Schmerzen haben sich erst danach richtig eingestellt.
Also, so konnte ich laufen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie nach dem Unfall Bauchschmerzen haben?
Bauchschmerzen nicht.
Nur eben diese Torachschmerzen,
diese Brustkorbschmerzen beim Einatmen.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn Unfall einmal Sturgang oder Wasalasen?
Und wie geht es aus?
Wahrscheinlich war ich auf dem Klo, ja.
Aber da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Welche Veränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe keine Veränderungen bemerkt.
Haben Sie Ihre Auswurf, irgendwelche Blut gesehen?
Noch mal bitte, wo?
Haben Sie Ihre Auswurf, Blut gesehen?
Ich habe kein Blut gehüstet.
Ich beschwerden, dass einatmen Probleme hat.
Nach dem Unfall mit der Zeit verschlägt hat oder verhindert.
Können wir als erstes eine Frage beginnen?
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind verstanden.
Hat doch jemand eine?
Ich weiß nicht, ob irgendjemand hat gerade etwas gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Dr. Yüthel war oder jemand anderes.
Nein, gut.
Dr. Yüthel?
Ja, ich bin bereit.
Ja, gut.
Guten Tag Frau Berersen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Sie haben neuen Patienten aufgenommen?
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Der Herr Kurt Bergmann ist ein 50-jähriger Patient.
Er ist bei uns seit zwei Stunden bestehender, stärker Schmerzen
im rechten Handgelenk und auch rechte Seite des Toraks.
Beim Zustand nach Sturz vom Motorrad auf der rechten Seite
auf der rechten Seite, er berichtete, dass das gelenk momentan
ein Helm getragen hat.
Darüber hinaus gibt er an auf der betroffenen Seite
die Äquemus, Exkoriation und Hauptabschürfungen zu haben.
Er hat gegendisch im Mercen einmal Kühe probiert.
Das hat ihm sehr wenig geholfen.
Zu dem haben wir Bewegungen und Einschränkungen des rechten Handgelenk.
Darüber hinaus berichtete er, dass die Schmerzen in der Hand ausstrahlen würden.
Die vegetative Anähe war unaufwendig, bis auf Diore.
Er hat die Schmerzen für die 45-jährige und die Schmerzen für die 45-jährige
eine Stereo-Stereo-Gesäufe.
Unterzogen.
Okay.
Bei ihm sei eine Kontressmittelallergie bekannt, diesig mit Exantem und Prüritus oysere.
Ja, er ist raucher, aber momentan rauche er ja sehr wenig nur 50eritten am Tag.
Aber vorher habe ich 20 Jahre lang eine Packung Zigaretten geraucht, das entspricht einem 20-Päck-Jurts-Ungefähr.
Er hat immer noch einen Tag im Abend gebraucht.
Was ist das?
Ja, unterzogen.
Er hat immer noch einen Tag im Abend gebraucht.
Sagen Sie nochmal, ein bisschen lebt der Vater noch oder lebt er nicht mehr?
Nein, er ist an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Der ist daran verstorben?
Ja, das war die Storne.
Die Analystischen Angaben deuten am Herstern auf eine Handgelenkfraktur und gleichzeitig stumpfestoraks Trauma hin.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch?
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit den Patienten?
Ich möchte zuerst den Patienten körperliche untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie dabei besonders?
Ja besonders. Ich achte auf perferaldurchspulutung, motorik und sensurik um eine Gefäßprobleme,
um die Abkühlung oder die Muskeln zu abschulissen.
Und dann zur weiteren Abkühlerung werden eine rundgen Untersuchung durchgeführt.
Was untersuchen Sie radiologisch?
Radiologisch möchte ich Handgelenk und Elbujung gelenk,
zwei Ebenen rundgenaufnahme und auch Trauaks rundgenaufnahme durchgeführt werden.
Ja, sehr gut.
Was sind denn sichere Frakturzeichen?
Ja, ich sehe Frakturzeichen, die sich von der Zeit der Ergebnisse nachweisieren.
Das ist klar. Aber im Vorfeld?
Ja, Feld, offene Fraktur.
Und Verstellte, Extremitäten oder...
Verstellungen.
Und dann gibt es noch etwas Gemeines?
Auch unangenehme Bewegungen.
Ja, unphysologische Bewegungen.
Was können Sie hören?
Ja, wir können auch Kreptation im Handgelenk hören.
Allein der Gedanke tut weh, finde ich.
Ja, ja.
Was machen Sie denn labortechnisch mit dem Patienten?
Labortechnisch möchte ich kleines Bild, Bulutgruppe und Nierenwerte,
und Gerünungparameter.
Gerünungparameter auch, wenn ich überpulse.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wäre das auch ganz sinnvoll.
Da kam mir vorhin eine Frage eines Kollegen,
dass man den Urin mal untersucht, ob der vielleicht doch Blutspuren drin hat.
Das ist auch...
Das könnte man noch so der guten Ordnung halber mitmachen.
Das machen Sie denn noch, bevor Sie mit ihm jetzt zum Röntgen gehen?
Was würden Sie noch machen?
Vor dem Röntgen.
Er hat Atemprobleme.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Vor dem Röntgen würde ich Bulutgasanalyse oder Bulutsaug.
Ja, nicht schlecht, Sauerstoff-Sättigung oder sowas.
Ja, Elektro-Cardiografie war schon...
Ja, ich meine, ich meine jetzt noch etwas anderes.
Ja, gut, die Rebitalparameter, ich denke, weil das hat er sowieso vorne weggemacht.
Dann, ich denke, man könnte noch gut einmal einen Schalkopf auf den Bauch halten.
Dass man guckt, ob das Zwergfeld hochsteht,
ob die Milz etwas abgekriegt hat oder so.
Dass man einmal einen Bauch ab dummen Sonomacht
und noch einmal guckt, ob da auf den ersten Blick irgendwas ist.
Ja, das ist auch richtig.
Gut, dann bin ich einmal gespannt, was unser Patient dann tatsächlich hat.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden.
Was machen Sie denn mit dem, wenn der tatsächlich eine Handgelingfraktur
und die Rippenfrellung hat?
Was machen Sie dann mit ihm?
Ja, ich würde gerne eine Orte für die Schäbkünste veranlasen,
ob er eine Operation braucht.
Aber vorher würde ich ja schonung, kühlung, Legierung und mit Gips oder Verwandt stabilisieren,
wenn er deswegen seiner Turaksrellung relativ immobilisiert ist,
was machen Sie dann noch?
Physiotherapie oder?
Erst mal kriegt er natürlich etwas gegen die Schmerzen.
Ich denke, Sie machen die Schugern geben, die etwas nicht.
Ich würde gerne auch Schmerz mit anderen Objektivitäten geben.
Aber ich denke gerade noch an etwas anderes.
Denken Sie an Immobilität?
Ja, ich würde gerne eine niedromolekuläre Heparin anfangen,
weil Immobilisation ist gefährlich für Turumbose.
Genau, TVD-Probe lag sehr gut.
Okay, also ich würde sagen, Sie sind nichts schuldig geblieben.
Sehr schön.
Ja, war eine schöne Anamnese, war ein schöner Bericht.
Ich glaube, das war auch ein schöner Fall.
So ein Unfall gibt immer mehr her als ein internistischer Masien, oder?
Ja, ja.
Und in München gibt es Unfälle, ne?
Ja, gibt es Unfälle.
Ja, insofern habe ich hier direkt mal einen Treffer gelandet.
Die Düsseldorfer können mit den Unfällen immer nichts anfangen, ne?
Einmal Unfall, aber nicht besonders.
Nach der Teleschipilin, eine Torstin.
Den habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ja, einmal.
Ah, okay.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, vielleicht ist das sogar auch ein Münchner Fall, den ich hier habe.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Aber ich habe den jedenfalls lange nicht gemacht.
Und ich finde den eigentlich ganz spannend mit den zwei Geschichten, ne?
Weil man dann einmal die Hand und einmal die Rippen hat.
Und dass man einmal so dieses Unfallmanagement eigentlich auch abrufen kann.
Und ich finde, das haben Sie sehr schön gemacht.
Und sprachlich, also ein paar Winzigkeiten, da sage ich etwas,
was ich fast immer sage.
Wenn wir über die Drogen sprechen, kein bestimmten Artikel, gar keinen Artikel.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen gehabt?
Oder haben Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nicht mit den Drogen?
Ja, mit welchen denn?
Also, kein Artikel.
Wenn Sie in den Supermarkt gehen, sagen Sie ja auch nicht, wo finde ich die Milch,
sondern Sie sagen, wo finde ich Milch?
Oder wo finde ich Obst und Gemüse?
Also, kein bestimmter Artikel.
Dann, das, ja, er nimmt genauso, er nimmt eine Tropfen.
Eine ist Singular und Tropfen ist Plural.
Also, er nimmt Tropfen, deren Name er nicht kennt.
Ja, der Name ist eben nicht geläufig.
Auch da kein Artikel.
Und dann, das ist jetzt ein bisschen spitzfindig, aber die Verneinung.
Er habe kein Bewusstsein verloren.
Die Verneinung bezieht sich aber eigentlich auf das, auf das Verb.
Nämlich, er hat das Bewusstsein nicht verloren.
Ich habe, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Dann bezieht sich kein auf das Nomen.
Ja, oder ich habe keinen Hunger.
Aber ich kann nachts nicht schlafen, bezieht sich auch das Verb.
Und er hat nicht das Bewusstsein verloren.
Ja, ist sehr spitzfindig sprachlich, aber es ist mir aufgefallen.
Und wenn Sie mich vor einem Jahr gefragt hätten,
wann sagt man nicht und wann sagt man kein, hätte ich das nicht gewusst?
Ich habe das in der Grammatik gelernt.
Also, er hat das Bewusstsein nicht verloren.
Ja, das ist also schon sehr, sehr speziell.
Ansonsten denke ich mal, das, was so ein Sprachniosen drin war,
das zählt unter der Rubrik.
Ein bisschen darf man das hören, das ist charmant, dass Sie kein Muttersprachler sind.
Das muss nicht immer 100%ig perfekt sein.
Aber Sie haben sich wirklich sehr, sehr gut geschlagen, finde ich.
Also, sehr gut.
Alles klar.
Ich denke, Dank.
Vielen Dank.